Do you want to understand
your favorite Disney movies?
Well this lesson is based on the themes and
characters of one of Pixar's best movies: Wall-e.
It has no spoilers, so don't
worry if you haven't seen it.
And if one of your goals is to understand all the
jokes and not get lost, even without subtitles,
then you are in luck because you found the YouTube
channel that will help you to achieve this goal.
Like Henrique who says that he can understand
90% after our lessons, so hit that Subscribe
button and the Bell down below, so that we can
help you with new lessons every single week.
Now let me tell you how this lesson is structured:
so first Andrea and I will introduce you to
the story of the movie, by talking about
the setting, main character, and theme.
Then, as we do that, you'll learn some vocabulary
related to the story of the movie and then we
will have a chat about this beautiful movie
involving this cute little robot named Wall-E.
If you've enjoyed this lesson you can catch all of
our lessons with your favorite
Disney movies in this playlist.
Just click up here or down the description box
below and watch that after you finish the test!